foreign
[Music]
for Thursday November 17th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
in September Russian President Vladimir
Putin ordered a mass mobilization of men
to support the country's war in Ukraine
that order spurred many men of fighting
age including from its Tech sector to
leave the country
it's actually the second recent Exodus
of tech workers from Russia a lot of
them left last winter when the invasion
was announced but this is believed to be
a far bigger wave of Departures as those
who couldn't leave last time now look
for an exit so what does this mean for
Russia's struggling economy and what
happens next for these highly skilled
workers
joining us to discuss all of this is our
reporter Yulia chernova hi Yulia thanks
for joining me thank you Yulia some
estimates show as many as a million
people left Russia this spring that
includes software developers and other
Tech workers that can do their jobs
remotely so where are they going the
biggest beneficiary is probably Georgia
and then other countries that offer an
easier transition whether they have a
visa-free entry or an easy way of
obtaining a Visa so Kazakhstan is a big
beneficiary than you have in Europe
Serbia is another destination that's
pretty large there is interesting
research by professor at Vienna
University of economics and business who
looked at GitHub accounts of Russian
developers GitHub is a software platform
where developers collaborate
and a hegeol located the accounts of
Russian developers to see whether they
are listing a new location for
themselves so what he found was that as
of November 8th about 13 of Russian
developers Now list a different country
than they did at the start of this year
and another 13 just obscured their
location and he estimates that about 20
percent of Russian developers have left
the country this year and the biggest
destination according to his research is
Georgia
and how easy is it for these Tech
workers to to find a new job or are they
keeping the positions that they had when
they were still in Russia a lot of them
actually are keeping their jobs some of
the Russian companies did adjust their
own policies to allow their workers to
continue remotely at the same time a lot
of the people I spoke with are trying to
find other jobs and it's not that easy
to get paid abroad you know they're
getting paid in rubles in Russia and
transferring that money out isn't simple
especially with all kinds of sanctions
and problems with the monetary
transactions cross-border right now with
Russia and in general there's a lot of
uncertainty in the Russian economy there
are reasons not to be tied closely to
these Russian companies so these workers
are looking as best they can what does
that mean for the you know startups or
Russian tech companies that have hired
these workers you know how easy is it
for the companies to survive once their
employees are leaving the country there
was a big dislocation and panic and
pause and just work itself by many Tech
teams in Russia right around the time
when mobilization was announced some say
that by now things have settled down and
people are adjusting and having workers
abroad is somewhat manageable for these
companies but it also depends on what
kind of work and what kind of projects
they are performing if they're working
for the government let's say it's harder
to justify having data transferred
across borders let's say or are any of
these companies having to consider
shutting down or moving their operations
entirely out of Russia yes we certainly
saw a lot of companies move their own
operations abroad I spoke with one
company for example in drive it's a ride
sharing startup that was founded in
Siberia in Russia currently it's based
in Silicon Valley it's backed by
American investors and most of their
workers were based in Russia they had
more than a thousand at the beginning of
this year and they are relocating
everybody out of the country this
company in particular has a lot of
people moving to Kazakhstan and Cyprus
whoever is not leaving the CEO said will
be laid off can you give us a sense of
how important the tech sector is to
Russia's economy and I guess how that
has changed since the start of the war
and since this new Exodus of tech
workers the tech sector is certainly
important for the Russian economy it's
estimated between three and six percent
of the country's GDP it was one of the
faster growing sectors of the economy
and it was also a sector that helped the
economy
diversify the Russian economy is very
much dependent on oil and gas revenue
and the tech sector was also important
in supplying a lot of well-paid jobs so
certainly the departure from the country
is a hit to the consumer market and in
general it's also a tax hit the income
taxes that these folks were paying to
the treasury are likely not going to be
paid in Russia and also Tech is
important to the government it supports
other sectors and the development of
other sectors and it's also important
just for the defense industry for cyber
security so then what does this kind of
brain drain mean long term for Russia
and its Ambitions within Tech you have
hundreds of thousands of smart educated
motivated well-off people leaving the
country it's a loss for Russia and again
for a wherever they end up at the same
time it's not to say that everything
stopped and all the tech companies
closed in Russia they are still growth
there and some companies are doing okay
and some of these companies are doing
even better than they thought they would
be back in the spring so it remains to
be seen what happens but the general
uncertainty is a big problem for the
tech sector because Founders are scared
to invest further all right that's our
reporter Yulia chernova thanks so much
for joining us thank you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]